let's edit this I'm not the English
man's whole career what color I'm not
around what career I'll call you
however I like don't worry about what
I'm gonna call you how I'm gonna call
you yeah let's get to the point oh sorry
okay oh so sorry let me let me think one
second
are you is your heart is broken sorry
you're the same guy who's insulting our
prophet and you want me to be respectful
to you you home you're emotional now you
know I feel like I'm watching Titanic
when the boat is sinking listen my stop
China let's get to the point get to the
point yeah let's talk don't talk
when you're on camera you act all gas
and when you hear you acting like you're
Romeo get to the point get to the point
man listen I respect the person who's
respectful you're not respectful you're
not going to get my respect what you
want a cookie
so but it won't you - Josh I'll take you
to creams exactly there you go oh you've
got to me so badly you've hurt me so
badly okay yes whatever makes you happy
let's get to the point
why are you crying for are you okay why
are you crying listen stop are you okay
stop stop being emotional
crying okay let me out later I'm going
to listen to you I'm gonna seal it out
never said nothing like that tell you I
never said nothing like that you're
chatting monsters just carry on okay
there you go
you're a coward you're a coward you're
not gonna talk out you're gonna run away
there you go
this is a coward are you happy now are
you happy now yeah okay good good no
problem let's get to the point no
problem let's get to the point no
problem you can prank me whenever you
like whenever you like whenever you feel
upset call me
no problem no problem no problem let's
get to the point okay let's get to the
point okay go on so you mentioned three
things yeah you mentioned surah walkie I
swore at or that they're going to be
young boys that's going to be serving
the people in paradise yeah so my
question to you is very simple into the
point yeah can you tell me where yeah
they stopped your car then yeah I don't
care how much you boys call enough to do
my topic turn it turn it off and we'll
talk listen to me yeah irrelevant okay
surah surah walkie and surah Toria okay
so we're gonna be talking about you
claim that these boys some kind of I
don't know where you got this perverted
understanding because I'll be honest
with you yeah last time I discussed this
with a guy he was he had some kind of
obsession with little boys as well yeah
so I don't know cuz only a person cuz I
read this a lot of Muslims read this in
sort of our case were told that in
Jannah in paradise there is no recorded
there's good there's going to be there's
going to be boys that I'm gonna serve us
now I want you to give me evidence from
the court and the Sunnah from the Sahaba
from the Thai bein from the tabi tabi in
anyone who has understood this verse to
be these little boys that you're going
to be having some kind of intimacy or
some kind of sexual perversion no no you
answer my question
which I did which are you chief
one second one second we need to check
that because I think it's in your story
let me check your story one second one
second so let me just read out so when
otherwise apostle went to answer the
call of nature I along with another boy
used to carry a tumbler full of water
for cleaning the private parts and then
and thus spearheaded stuck yes is it
that one okay okay whenever I'm not
supposed to answer the call of nature I
along with another boy from us used to
go behind him with it okay before that
no for the profits are seldom said to
abu talha choose one of your boy
servants to serve me in my expedition to
high bar so abu talha took me letting me
ride behind him while I was a boy
nearing the age of puberty I used to
serve a lot apostle when he stopped to
rest I heard him saying repeatedly oh
allah i seek refuge with you from
distress and sorrow from helplessness
and laziness and have for miserliness
and cowardness
from being heavily in debt and from
being overcome by men this was once a
once a one second one second bhava you
turned it into a curry one second one
second where does it say that these boys
I would have been love words doing what
you say what they saying can you show me
where it says that sorry okay let me see
I'm gonna read it yeah cuz I don't I'm
not under the influence anything here
so I'm reading it with a clear mind here
the Prophet said to abu talha choose one
of your boy servants to serve me in
expedition to hiber
so he's saying give me someone that can
help me help him with what once one
second was an argument sake no no
problem look was it most Oh
yes yes yes yes okay okay okay let me
get this okay is that are you finished
I've listened to you okay forgive me and
to be honest okay
I'm starting yeah let me finish now I'm
going to start off without because
usually somebody asked me this question
I would laugh at them or literally
question the insula I'm not going to do
that I'm going to do now I'm going to
assume I'm going to assume I'm gonna
assume now I'm going to assume you don't
know what you're talking about cause
it's clear in a way talking about what
you've done is the following
you've gotten there let me finish let me
finish let me finish
you've gone to the Book of jihad Chuck
143 and you've took this verse from
I know Bravo it's the title had it Brava
Brava I know you I'm going saying you're
going to the part of Bihari in about
your head my brother let me finish I
listen to you let me talk you've asked a
question
Buhari has different chapters about wudu
about the class this is the book of
jihad so let me finish so you've gone
and what you've done is the following
you've read this I what Allah is the one
who's narrating he's saying the Prophet
said choose one of your boy servants the
permit didn't say can you give me a
prepubescent one he says choose one of
your boy servants to serve me in my
expedition to khyber number one number
two so Abu Talha took me so Abu Talha is
the one who's choosing and he's chosen
somebody that's pre peasant argument's
sake let's say he's picked up RIBA cent
per child what has that got to do with
the connection of a separate issue of I
shall and I know and her talking about
her scrubbing of semen on the clothes of
the Prophet peace be upon him how did
you make the the the the you've inserted
that the Prophet was masturbating how
did you connect all of this and then you
went to store a walk here and correct in
connecting that or there's going to be
literal boys how are you making these
connections when nowhere I let me finish
I've listened to you this shows this is
the most idiotic argument I've heard let
me you know tell you why let me let me
finish let me finish let me finish I
have to finish I have to finish I have
to finish I have to finish number one
let me tell you something you are the
most idiotic guy I've seen you know why
nowhere let me finish
stop look look look look look look
listen listen if I've got the brain of
Optimus you've got no brain at least
I've got some brain to work with yeah
listen forget that hominins let me
finish I have a finished my point can
you please once again can you please
tell me where in the hadith and where in
surah surah surah wackier which scholar
said that these boys they're going to be
intimate with these boys please ask my
question please can you tell me where in
the hadith where in the Quran does it
say that these boy
you can have intimacy with can you
please answer that can you please answer
little boy you're a boy you're a boy
you're finished you're finished you're
finished yeah like in the absence now
can you answer me yet you're a little
child can you show me don't cry listen
bro Internet after this after this come
and work for me I do Darwin speakers
corner you can hold posters up from here
listen you're rinsed your finished
answer my question answer my question
please answer my question please answer
my question answer my question answer my
question stop smoking weed it's killing
your brain cells you're not thinking
straight
please answer my question where does it
say the Prophet masturbated where does
it say that the Prophet used the boy to
wash that wash him off be finished
toilet please tell me where is shorter
walk here so that or does it say that
these boys are going to be you're gonna
use it for intimate reasons you're a
perverted dirty man you said here the
wet dream listen yes okay yeah yes yes
depends for example if the prayer time
is two hours if I if I if if let's say
if somebody has had a wet dream if they
know there's two hours they can go to
the supermarket do their shopping come
back and then have about what's the
point on comes to but understand him
look some people know something might do
one second if it's not the time for
prayer I've got three hours to vote I
repeat again if somebody's had a wet
dream and they know prayer time is in
three hours they could go out there is
no Sun doesn't say that it's Haram for
you to go out if you're in Geneva yeah
it doesn't say that it says that if
there's free hours I can go to the
supermarket go buy a close-combat kind
of shower and go Juma what is your point
I don't understand how it's this is what
I'm seeing one second let me tell you
how let me tell you how excuse me excuse
me excuse me let me tell us look can you
okay what something can you please show
me okay can you please show me where in
the hadith it said that this boy washed
his private parts if you see if we just
prove to me that this boy washed his
private parts please do yeah exactly
that's what I think what that what the
hell but what are you talking about
you're all over the place
listen listen can you please stop is he
you can't answer it you're finished
look you're finished this is being
recorded you are being remediated you're
being humiliated show me where in the
hadith it says no cooker you can finish
his argument you can finish me off with
one thing show me a hadith that the
Prophet said that young boy washed his
private parts I challenge you
boom ma'am
listen you're a little child listen here
I'm asking you show me the hadith that
says the boy washed his private parts oh
my gosh once again can you show me
stop crying man listen listen listen I
don't know what you're going through in
life but why you listen listen
my friend listen I seem that look I'm
asking you something one second
the point here is hello my friend you're
talking about the boy can you show me
where that little boy watched his
private parts please I'm not an English
man's whole career why are you answering
where did the boy was the prophet's
private parts unless you're a perverted
man who likes little boys this is a
different story can you show me you're a
clown buff you're a idiot you're a clown
I'm telling you I'm telling you where in
the hadith does it say the boy was his
private parts show me where it says it
was his private parts please I beg you
yeah okay oh you think I'm scared of you
no listen if you want to come meet you
now look look look look you tell you
[ __ ] I'm skinny let's say listen don't
swear to me buff yeah
don't threaten me don't threaten me well
I don't care who you are what you are I
don't care don't come fraction in me
don't come to me child you don't know
who I am
brother you are nobody you said you
drive a 500 pound car shut your mouth
shut up is it be quiet man don't come to
me listen listen you're a little child
I've got no problem meeting you but
don't come here threatening me if you I
don't kill you all you're talking about
Islam let's talk about Islam okay guys
I'm going to talk to the camera brothers
and sisters as you can see now you can't
argue my questions what's he doing now
oh you don't know who I am why you going
to difference but if you want listen
listen if you want your killer Klown you
can't answer it there you go
brothers and sisters what Allah he look
do you know why I did this for if
there's one reason I did this is to show
you guys some people are saying all
somebody left a stamp I won't leave my
dirty socks for this guy this guy is an
absolute clown where in the Hadees look
I brought all of this together why he's
done his mishmash
get this hadith there's a Priebus a boy
okay and then he goes another hadith
that the process seldom had see me on
the cross and I she was cleaning it
what's that got to do with it so for
example if a woman if a man has intimacy
with his wife he finishes and obviously
we know semen can't come out after you
have done that and and let's see the
wife is going to wash his clothes and he
sees that this semen there and he washes
it how is that connected to this heavy
of a professing boy how is that
connected this shoulder toward a surah
wackier brothers and sisters while llahi
one way this is these little kids Jerry
something wrong sisters here
you know why you went to the level of
starting to friend me all you don't you
do you don't know who I am I know you
you're a little kid why did why did
somebody go to the level of You Know Who
I am
Brett because he realized he has no
arguments he just got literally
humiliated destroyed look I'm asking him
please show me all you have to do is in
this hadith it says that the boy was the
prophet's private part look look I asked
him a simple question brothers and
sisters one light this is the reason why
please don't waste your time with this
clown yeah don't waste your time he has
no idea what he's talking about he's
gained the Quran turn it into a stupid
mishmash bring it here make some curry
and hundred I lost want I like so
exposes when the truth is both for false
for parishes mean threatening me I don't
know who I am I don't know I don't give
a damn who the hell you are man be a man
be a man we debate don't come to me I
don't know I don't care you know yeah so
Roman sis is the word Ghulam that's
mentioned that this little boy is
talking about yeah okay that the states
would childhood yeah it has free mint
meaning some kitty
it's tough see it he says that it means
a young boy a slave or a grown man yeah
these are one of the three meanings yeah
okay well obviously one of the meanings
that we can have for this little child
this little boy is a little boy yeah
that's maybe one of the things that
understand is that we can have about him
but referring to the poor and he has one
of these meanings brothers and sisters
yeah
so this mowlam actually got destroyed
inshallah and hope this is a lesson for
you guys don't get these little kids
they just bought this guy is probably
going through something in his life when
we ask God to guide him one like a
minister he seems like he's oil free
song he's frustrated he's not happy
look may Allah guide you you know you
seem very lost and you are nothing
better to do your Instagram of little
kids yeah hope that's clarified it
assalamu alaikum whatever hit okay guys
so i'm supposed to release
yesterday but I came across more funny
stuff from our friend yeah
now here's another evidence why this guy
is full up perverted you see when a
person for example if I'm a thief yeah I
would think everybody's a thief like me
so for example I would never entrust
anyone the money why cuz I've seen look
I'm a thief um if that was me I would
steal your money so I would not give
anyone my money so you see when someone
has this kind of ideology of PD like
pedophilic interested in little boys
perverted sees everything the sexual he
thinks that everybody is like him when
you read this hadith yeah when you read
the said if look another example the
Prophet peace be upon him said whoever
entrust to me what is between his legs
and what is between his lips will be
granted paradise does any of you ever
think of the following
look you understand I understand this in
this way the Prophet is saying basically
if I keep my private parts away from
Zenor
yeah yeah and don't back by allowing
rapid paradise did any of you think when
I mention the thing of you guys said
this man can enter if they give Muhammad
what is between their legs be honest be
honest with me did any of you guys did
this go for your head you see the reason
why I didn't go for your head is because
you're a normal human being you don't
take drugs you don't smoke crack
you know what's porn yeah all this kind
of stuff probably that's why you never
saw that leave that way but a person
that's perverted and is interested in
little boys and all this kind of stuff
when he needs this he's thinking yo like
I'm a bit of a perv and I watch porn
gonna smoke crack and I smoked so much
weed it's Cleveland killed my brain
brain cells and I thought you hours
sleep this must mean that man can enter
if they give Muhammad was between their
legs yeah I've made a whole separate
video on this issue of Asia and I was
speaking with a non Muslim guy
look at his also the videos gonna be
here watch this the guy was convinced
watch the whole video so once again it
goes back to only a perverted person
would have a problem with this year
finally I'm gonna finish on this is that
he's brought weak hadith yeah about the
Prophet peace be upon him that I was a
bit lost sucking the lips of Hasan and
Ali
this guy's a violin if there's another
thing I don't want to mention it's whoa
yeah all of them a weak hadith
absolutely
yeah we know hadith to be authentic it
has to be the narrates the narration the
scene has to be connected the narrator
has to be reliable his memory should be
good
there should be no defects and no
opposition to the hadith yeah we could
be this fabricated so everything is
bringing is fabricated so brothers and
sisters as you can see please do not
waste your time with these kind of
people this is what happens wrong
sisters it's what drugs do to you don't
take drugs you know this what's in it
please don't take drugs what like a cow
an animal what let has more senses than
this guy yeah so brothers and sisters
please do not take drugs stay away from
drugs because as you can see this is
what can happen to you till next time
brother and sisters may Allah bless you
guys to watch this video do not forget
to share this with your friends and
family assalamu alaikum what happened to
a better schedule and do not forget to
watch the video that i had a discussion
about I showed on their Anna's marriage
to the Prophet peace be upon him with a
person with a gentleman with a man who
doesn't take drugs is a normal human
being and look-wise respond was